اقتحام واسع نفذه جيش الاحتلال لمخيم
قلنديا استقدم خلاله عددا كبيرا من
الاليات العسكريه كما تشاهدون هذا التواجد
الكثيف لجيش الاحتلال عند مدخل المخيم هو
لما تبقى من اليات كانت قد تواجدت وانتشرت
بشكل واسع في داخل مخيم قلنديا في اطار
عمليه عسكريه نفذها جيش الاحتلال في داخل
المخيم هذه الع عمليه شهدت استقدام جيش
الاحتلال
لاسير فلسطيني كانت قد اعتقلته من المنطقه
قبل اسبوع واحضرت مكبلا
بالسلاسل الحديديه يرتدي زي الشباز وكذلك
درعا وخوذه وقامت
بتجول في شوارع المخيم وعند مدخله وهي
تصطحب هذا الشاب معها في اطار الممارسات
المختلفه التي يقوم بها جيش الاحتلال خلال
اقتحاماتها المتواصله للضفه الغربيه حسن
مسعود الجزيره من مدخل مخيم قلنديا
شمال القدس